what could be more powerful than a god
goku's son gohan found a way to once
again surpass his dad in dragon ball
super superhero longtime fans of the
dragon ball franchise have seen power
levels go from simple strength and speed
enhancements to almost world-ending
destructive forces vegeta what did you
say his power level is
it's over 9 000.
near the start of the original dragon
ball series the young goku accidentally
taps into the cataclysmic power of his
saiyan nature by transforming into a
giant bloodthirsty ape this form is
known as uzaru and although it provides
incredible strength all logic and
reasoning go out the window it's this
ability that enables alien saiyans to
attack and subjugate other species
expanding their universe spanning empire
even the very youngest of saiyans can
lay waste to entire worlds by simple
exposure to moonlight goku doesn't share
the world conquering hunger of his
fellow saiyans but he does share their
love of intense combat eventually goku
starts his own family and his firstborn
son is gohan young gohan at first doubts
his powers because of his half-human
half-saiyan blood but it is soon
revealed that his power can dwarf even
that of goku when gohan absolutely
trounces cell at the end of the cell
saga since then gohan has unlocked even
greater power during the final saga of
dragon ball z gohan trained with old kai
to unlock a new ability he learns that
saiyan's channel and wastes a tremendous
amount of power while transforming into
the various super saiyan forms but old
kai's technique taught gohan to access
the enhanced speed and strength of a
super saiyan without the waist
incredible he's stronger than he ever
was as a super saiyan but he looks like
he hasn't changed a bit gohan stands toe
to toe with the malevolent entity known
as super boo but he eventually retires
from fighting to instead focus on his
home life and burgeoning family his
combat prowess begins to fade from his
lack of training but the new movie
dragon ball super superhero sees the
spotlight casts back onto gohan and his
childhood mentor piccolo the movie kicks
off with a reconstituted red ribbon army
seeking vengeance against piccolo and
gohan with a plan to kidnap gohan's
daughter to lure him into a trap and
unleash the devastation of the killer
android cell max piccolo and gohan gets
some rather potent power upgrades during
the course of the film piccolo uses the
power of the dragon balls to unlock his
orange form which grants him tremendous
fighting abilities yet even with his
enhanced power piccolo falls to sell max
and as in the past seeing a friend get
hurt leads gohan to tap into previously
unseen powers of his own gohan unlocks a
new power level called gohan beast which
resembles a super saiyan 2 look the key
differences are that his hair is silver
instead of yellow and his eyes turn red
his aura is augmented with red arcing
lightning bolts that's herman crackle
with power in this form gohan is easily
able to defeat the powerful villain
gohan once again catapulting to the
upper echelons of power among the z
fighters is such a momentous event that
series creator akira toriyama had to
address it in a statement on the
official japanese twitter account for
dragon ball super toriyama said gohan is
actually stronger than anyone or so it
said but lately he hasn't really gotten
a chance to shine in order to motivate
gohan it takes his revered teacher
piccolo rather than his father goku i
figured i'd try giving birth to a new
superhero by putting these two in the
spotlight to their intense battles with
the gamma androids this really is a
return to form for gohan who in dragon
ball z was considered one of the
strongest fighters alive goku and vegeta
have absolutely dominated the power
rankings of dragon ball super with their
recently acquired god powers but it
seems that with gohan's latest
transformation he once again has
currently the highest level of power
currently possible in the dragon ball
franchise